to try to put all of this in perspective
we are joined by royanika Royal editor
of the Sunday Times and the CBS News
contributor good morning
so in the Memoir Prince Harry shares
some very personal details none of which
paint his father the king or his brother
the Future King in a good light what do
you believe is his motivation for
sharing all of this
I mean that is the massive question that
no one can quite understand at the
moment I think you know part of it from
you know the clips that we've heard from
Harry in those interviews with the
Anderson Cooper into coming up as well
is he seems almost unburdened you know
from the restrictions of being in the
royal family he sees this as now his
first opportunity to really speak freely
but in terms of motivation I think
from what I consider glean and unpick he
is very keen for the world to know that
he felt he had a very very rough deal
inside the royal family particularly
towards the end but actually this notion
of being the spare is something that
he's felt ever since he was very young I
mean the detail about him having a
smaller part of a bedroom at Balmoral
Castle than William it really has been
you know been there right from the very
start and I think you know when you try
and unpick the motivation it's just that
he has felt very very slighted all his
life and perhaps undervalued as the
spare
Roya Harry has said he wants his father
and his brother back what are you
hearing from your sources about whether
there's any appetite for reconciliation
especially after this book
you know I it's interesting that's
something that I picked up on actually
before Christmas that Harry wanted to
Summit and he wants accountability and
he wants to sit down with the family the
very very tricky thing from the family's
perspective is as we've seen in the last
few weeks with the Netflix documentary
and now with this with this you know
tell book every small personal detail of
you know the most intimate conversations
the most intimate scenarios you know
that bust up with William is being
reported in in excruciating detail and
that is going to obviously put the royal
family on real guard as to how on Earth
they could ever sit down and have a
summit or or speak to Harry with the
fear that everything they say is going
to be reported so there is that big
stumbling block there but in terms of
wanting a Reconciliation you know
Charles's people have consistently
briefed he loves his son the door is
always open they know where the king
lives
yeah Roy you only get one family so we
do hope they reconcile I am curious
we've got Harry here speaking in the
form of a very long uh book and all
these TV interviews will the palace in
some formal way sit down Grant an
interview talk about things from their
perspective
I don't think we'll have someone from
the past
sitting down and and giving an interview
but I think they will although we've
seen all the leaks in the last couple of
days they will want to sit down
themselves with the actual book when
it's published on Tuesday evaluate all
of it in context
and then potentially possibly
um if we were to hear anything from them
I think it would be something along the
lines of that very famous now statement
from the queen after Oprah Recollections
may vary but we're not going to get
someone I don't think from the palace
sitting down and unpicking all of this
and going on camera in the way that
we've seen Harry do
all right ryanika thank you so much we
hope there's a good conclusion here and
a reminder you could see Prince Harry's
60 Minutes interview with Anderson
Cooper this Sunday night right here on
CBS I will be watching me too